Ces réfugiés, dont de nombreuses familles,
sont piégés dans certaines des villes les plus dangereuses au monde,
où ils se font violer, kidnapper
et racketter par des groupes criminels.
Et s'ils survivent assez longtemps pour se rendre à leur audience,
moins de 1% d'entre eux parviennent à trouver un avocat
pour les aider avec leur dossier.
Le gouvernement réfère aux taux d'acceptation de demande d'asile
les plus bas
pour soutenir que ces gens ne sont pas de vrais réfugiés
quand, en réalité, la législation sur l'asile est un parcours d'obstacles
conçu pour les faire échouer.
Pas tous les migrants à la frontière sont des réfugiés.
J'ai rencontré beaucoup de migrants économiques.
Par exemple, certains veulent aller aux US pour travailler,
pour payer les frais médicaux d'un parent
ou les frais de scolarité d'un enfant resté au pays.
De plus en plus, je rencontre aussi des réfugiés climatiques.
Spécifiquement, je rencontre beaucoup d'indiens d'Amérique Centrale
qui ne peuvent plus vivre de l'agriculture
à cause de sécheresses catastrophiques dans la région.
Nous savons qu'aujourd'hui,
des gens migrent à cause du changement climatique
et que ça ne va qu'augmenter,
mais nous n'avons pas de système légal en place pour gérer ce type de migration.
Pour commencer, il serait logique
d'élargir la définition de réfugié
pour inclure les réfugiés climatiques, par exemple.
Mais ceux d'entre nous en mesure de militer pour ces changements
sommes trop occupés à poursuivre notre gouvernement
pour protéger les maigres protections légales dont les réfugiés bénéficient.
Nous sommes épuisés
et il est presque trop tard pour aider.
Et nous savons désormais
que ce problème n'est pas limité aux États-Unis.
Des centres de détention extracôtiers inhumains de l'Australie
à la criminalisation par l'Italie
de l'aide aux migrants se noyant dans la Méditerranée,
les pays développés ont déployé des efforts meurtriers
pour empêcher les réfugiés d'atteindre nos côtes.
Mais ils ont fait plus que de limiter la définition de réfugié.
Ils ont créé des systèmes légaux parallèles de style fasciste
dans lesquels les migrants n'ont aucun des droits
qui constituent la base de la démocratie,
la prétendue fondation des pays dans lesquels ils cherchent l'asile.
L'Histoire nous rappelle que le 1er groupe
à être vilipendé et privé de ses droits est rarement le dernier
et beaucoup d'Américains et d'Européens
semblent accepter un système légal opaque et injuste pour les non-citoyens
parce qu'ils pensent être à l'abri.
Mais un jour ou l'autre,
ces idéaux autoritaristes débordent et affectent également les citoyens.
Je l'ai découvert
quand le gouvernement m'a placée sur une liste de surveillance illégale
à cause mon aide aux immigrants à la frontière.
Un jour, en janvier 2019,
j'ai quitté mon travail à San Diego
et je suis allée traverser la frontière pour rentrer chez moi au Mexique.
Les agents mexicains, même s'ils m'avaient donné un visa valide,
m'ont arrêtée et dit que je ne pouvais pas rentrer dans le pays
parce qu'un gouvernement étranger
m'avait déclarée comme risque pour la sécurité nationale.
J'ai été détenue et interrogée dans une salle glauque pendant des heures.
J'ai supplié les agents mexicains
de me laisser retourner au Mexique pour récupérer mon fils
qui avait seulement dix mois à l'époque.
Mais ils ont refusé
et ils m'ont livrée aux agents du CBP,
qui m'ont forcée à retourner aux États-Unis.
Ça m'a pris des semaines pour obtenir un autre visa pour rentrer au Mexique.
Je suis allée à la frontière, mon visa à la main.
Mais à nouveau, j'ai été détenue et interrogée
parce que mon passeport était encore signalé aux autorités.
Peu après,
des documents internes du CPB ont fuité
qui confirmaient que mon propre gouvernement
avait été complice dans l'émission d'une alerte à mon encontre.
Depuis, je n'ai pas voyagé dans d'autres pays
car je crains d'être à nouveau détenue
et renvoyée à la frontière par ces pays.
Ces restrictions au voyage, ces détentions
et cette séparation avec mon fils
sont des choses que je n'aurais jamais pensé vivre
en tant que citoyenne américaine,
mais je suis loin d'être la seule à être criminalisée pour aider les immigrants.
Les États-Unis et d'autres pays ont fait de sauver des vies un crime
et ceux d'entre nous qui essayons juste de faire notre travail
sommes forcés de choisir entre notre humanité et notre liberté.
Et ce qui me désespère,
c'est que nous devons tous faire le même choix,
mais que vous ne l'avez pas encore compris.
Et je sais qu'il y a beaucoup de bonnes personnes.
J'ai vu des milliers d'entre vous dans la rue,
manifestant contre la séparation familiale.
Et ça a beaucoup aidé à changer la politique du gouvernement.
Mais le gouvernement continue à séparer les enfants de leur famille.
Et les choses ne font qu'empirer.
Aujourd'hui, notre gouvernement se bat pour obtenir le droit
de détenir les enfants réfugiés dans des prisons indéfiniment.
Ce n'est pas fini.
Nous ne pouvons pas nous autoriser à nous endormir ou à regarder ailleurs.
Ceux d'entre nous qui sont citoyens de pays
dont les politiques mènent à la détention, la séparation et la mort
devons décider très vite dans quel camp nous sommes.
Nous devons réclamer que nos lois respectent
la dignité de tous les êtres humains,
en particulier des réfugiés qui cherchent de l'aide à nos frontières
mais aussi des migrants économiques et des réfugiés climatiques.
Nous devons réclamer que les réfugiés aient réellement une chance
lorsqu'ils cherchent l'asile dans notre pays
en nous assurant qu'ils aient accès à un avocat
et en créant des tribunaux indépendants
qui ne sont pas influencés par les lubies politiques du Président.
Je sais que c'est accablant
et je sais que ça a l'air cliché, mais...
nous devons appeler nos représentants
et réclamer ces changements.
Je sais que vous avez déjà entendu ça,
mais est-ce que vous avez déjà agi ?
Nous savons que ces appels servent à quelque chose.
Ces systèmes d'immigration dystopiques qui sont développés dans les pays riches
sont un test pour les citoyens
pour voir jusqu'où vous êtes prêts à laisser le gouvernement
retirer leurs droits à d'autres gens quand vous pensez être à l'abri.
Si vous laissez le gouvernement retirer des enfants à leur famille
sans procédure équitable
et détenir des gens indéfiniment sans qu'ils aient accès à un avocat,
vous échouez au test.
Ce qui arrive aux immigrants aujourd'hui,
c'est ce qui pourrait vous arriver demain si nous n'agissons pas.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)